la france on le sait un sérieux déficit
commercial avec le japon pour autant la
présence française est déjà importante
dans le secteur du luxe le secteur de
l'habillement notamment et puis la façon
de vivre à la française est en train de
gagner le japon spécialement dans le
domaine de la restauration vous allez le
voir dans cette enquête d'isabelle
bechler et tristan le bras un café ou un
verre de vin rouge en terrasse l'art de
vivre français est sans doute une de nos
valeurs les plus exportables n'en
déplaise aux efforts des industries de
haute technologie pour modifier l'image
de la france
ici on a même pensé aux pigeons pour
faire tout à fait grands boulevards sur
les trottoirs de tokyo même les
travailleurs acharnés que sont les
japonais ont appris à flâner et à
prendre le temps de déguster un café
le concept parisien est adapté jusqu aux
commandes des garçons en français dans
le texte
une action d'éclat de la landi assez
claires la restauration française est de
nouveau le vent en poupe après une
grande bleed it here année n avancé et
le sol italien mode italienne cet
attrait mode se demande qui ne pense pas
ce que tu répètes 2 0 mais il demande de
lui demander le pape
maintenant ça je cois français qui monte
mais pourquoi c'est l'accusé montrait
bon qui vient pas très bien travaillé
autre style de restauration à la
française en plein quartier débit sous
le grand jeu d'un château taille et
pierre par pierre dans le poitou
dépaysement garanti dans un lieu auquel
taillevent héros bouchons ont prêté leur
nom
c'est la très grande cuisine de l'on
vient chercher ici préparé par une
armada de japonais qui ont souvent
travaillé dans des restaurants très
étoilé de france ici sous la direction
d'un chef breton qui a à coeur de
proposer la cuisine française dans ce
qu'elle a de plus sobre et raffiné à la
fois plus question de faire une cuisine
gains des eaux puis forcément
astronomiques
ils ont fait ce qu'ils étaient importés
au japon n'était peut-être pas la vraie
cuisine française actuelle avec le
respect du produit de bien choisir le
produit le mettre en valeur et respecte
et comprend que maintenant on est parti
sur une nouvelle vague et nous répond
progrès sont les jours et ça marche
pour séduire les japonais si exigeant et
qui sont déjà venus se faire le palais
en france on ne lésine pas veaux sous la
mère agneau de pauillac et omar de
bretagne tout ce qu'il ya de mieux
inciter les rouges mange français en
france j'ai toujours les stelliens je
retourne ici ça va pas non la cuisine
est à ranger au goût japonaise donc
c'est léger c'est bien le groupe des
brasseries sapporo ainsi jouer la carte
française pour un des établissements les
plus prestigieux de la capitale
japonaise